was this a different experience for you
adapting this book given that it had the
series of photographs within it most
people would say but books when they
read it everybody has their own their
imagination just sort of opens up and
it's like everybody has their own
interpretation of it and in a film which
is much more obvious visual that's all
sort of laid out there so the key is to
try to keep the feeling of the mystery
keep the feeling of discovery keep the
feeling of the book while it being a
different medium what does a Tim Burton
movie mean to you
what do you know you'll get when you say
that it's always very you know striking
very beautiful very moving weird
characters but to have a heart and also
there's always a sense of humor among
the darkness I feel like I watch every
Tim Burton movie with these big eyes you
know with this sense of childlike wonder
what is it like when you're on the set
does it feel the same it's the same it
is exactly the same every day you're
kind of like you know in these amazing
sets that they built which they really
are magical just the lighting and the
props and everything just really comes
together to really bring it all to life
yeah this movie looks perfect
for Tim Burton style how would you
describe the tone is it a fairy tale
yeah I'd say it's like a fairy tale it's
a fairytale fantasy adventure and but
there's a bit of everything in there you
know it's a little bit scary it's a
little bit funny sort of action in there
little stunts you know yeah it's a bit
of everything I love how he describes
your characters scary poppins
yeah and she's very protective over the
children what was it like working with
the cast other kids it was a bit
intimidated at the beginning I was like
oh god am i are they gonna like me you
know because I'm supposed to be kind of
like them kind of mother I loved you
know working actually with children and
those children anyway with gorgeous and
it's nice to see them acting because
they are not acting very natural you
know they are in the moment so that's
inspiring
I'll go after them [ __ ] I promise
you